like do you understand what's good
there's there's genocide going on right
now like what do you think's going on
like we lack perspective your conference
got [ __ ] up boohoo I lost a client
boohoo there's people [ __ ] dying out
there like like so when Americans or
Europeans talk to me about race or
gender I'm sad it's the real life but I
remind them because it's a positive
thing cool but let me tell you about the
person that's ranked seven billion in
the world they [ __ ] have it bad
without really listen you know I got hot
on this about a year ago the four
hundred trillion to one it's impossible
to be a human being you won
[Music]
400 trillion to 1 when you understand
that math how can't you live your life
that's how rare it is to be a human
being you've been given this ridiculous
triple miracle you've got one at back
please do something about it we are
living through the greatest era to be
alive ever yes there's stuff I got news
for you there's always stuff but when
you take control of your at-bat when you
put it all on yourself when it's your
fault and your wins when you own it
that's when it starts happening
so please please squeeze the [ __ ] out of
your
[Music]
it's impossible to be a human being you
want I don't know how to get upset after
that I keep [ __ ] in perspective you know
what I'm always happy I believe myself
when you blame yourself for real
you're gonna always be happy because you
don't feel like somebody else controls
you this is the reason I'm happy 24/7
365 for the rest of my life or hundred
trillion to one the odds of becoming a
human being it's it's about eliminating
being at the mercy of anything or anyone
like I just don't give a [ __ ] what
anybody thinks you've got to start with
yourself because when you're actually
allowing other people to get in you're
vulnerable on me on me I'm my fault
there's nothing you can say my big thing
is don't complain you're in control
so many people are keyboard activists
right everybody's good at sending a
tweet about how the world should be and
nobody's doing anything about it and
that just that is just very much human
nature if you're complaining do
something enough I don't know if anybody
knows but slavery has been gone for a
while
your boss might be the biggest jerk of
all time but guess what you can go get
another job right now wrap your head
around this ridiculous gift that you
were given it's called life
you're using your [ __ ] eyes to watch
this and your ears to listen go step out
and do your thing the one thing you've
always wanted to do or the ten fifty a
hundred things you've always tried to do
because the only thing that's keeping
you back is the other people that are
judging you and who gives a [ __ ] about
them